living in New York now is dangerous that
state needs new leadership and it looks
like it's about to get it as we told you
Lee zeldon is running for governor a new
poll today an independent coefficient
survey shows Eldon leading the incumbent
in the race for the first time
Congressman Lee zeldon Joins us now
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on it's pretty remarkable not that we
didn't have faith in you as a person but
I mean it's an overwhelmingly Democratic
State and you're now winning the
governor's race oh
first congratulations second what do you
attribute this to
I mean you have a governor who's just
not doing a good job she's unlikable
she's corrupt she's pandering to
criminals she's pandering to tax and
spend liberals she's advancing woke
policies as opposed to just focusing on
what is most important to New York
voters if she was tackling Rising crime
if she was tackling skyrocketing costs
then this might be a different campaign
but here we are talking about how we
need to remove District Attorneys when
they refuse to enforce the law we don't
have recall elections in New York but
the governor does have the
Constitutional authority to get rid of a
D.A who refuses to do their job we're
over here talking about the need to get
rid of cashless battle and some of these
other pro-criminal laws and we need to
support our men and women in law
enforcement who are being hung out to
dry getting the handcuffs thrown on them
as opposed to putting the handcuffs on
criminals we have a state ban on the
safe extraction of natural gas and now
Kathy hokel wants to get rid of all gas
powered vehicles here over the course of
the next decade we just had the new CDC
guidance come out where they're adding
the covid vaccine into their list and
you have a governor who is talking about
as a possible consideration her past
remarks have indicated that maybe she
would mandate that for kids but we
already have it uh being required on
college students and we have people who
are getting fired for their refusal to
get the coveted vaccine like our health
care workers who used to be held as
Heroes now treated as zeros I'm somebody
who believes that there should be no
covet vaccine on anyone whether it's
grade school higher ed employment or
otherwise and everyone who should be
fine who was fired should be getting
their jobs back with back pay so the
contrast is clear and even Democrats in
Independents are saying you know what we
have to go a new New Direction in order
to save the state Kathy hokel has to go
and she will on November 8th
it sounds like she will it's just a
remarkable story it kind of comes out of
nowhere because again it's so
overwhelmingly Democratic it almost
seems like she's trying to wreck the
state
where we are out here campaigning our
tails off to earn the support of Voters
to do our part to save the state Kathy
Holcomb right now is crawling across the
Finish Line she's trying to survive this
campaign and clearly her goal here is to
save Kathy hokel and the average voter
out there in New York hitting their
breaking point in the state listen
there's a reason why New York leads the
entire nation in population laws Tucker
and I don't even think that Kathy hokel
can finish this sentence that New York
leads the entire nation in population
loss because and if you can't finish
that sentence no one's going to ever
expect you to actually fix this and a
lot of people pick up on it
so nicely put
wow congratulations Congressman Lee
zeldin of New York hopefully the next
Governor looks like you will be thank
you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight